tenemos aquí cuatro parejas de números
donde del lado izquierdo tenemos números
mixtos y del lado derecho tenemos
fracciones impropias y lo que queremos
es en cada una de estas parejas
determinar cuál de estos dos números es
más grande ok entonces vamos a empezar
con uno y siete octavos y hay que decir
si es más grande o más chico que treinta
y nueve décimos entonces lo primero que
se me ocurre a mí es agarrar el 39 y
dividirlo entre 10 o sea tenemos que
escribir aquí un 3 si hubiéramos escrito
un 4 nos quedaría 40 y eso sí ya no cabe
dentro del 39 no entonces 3 por 10 son
y restamos y nos quedan 9 de residuos
así es que 39 décimos es 3 enteros y 9
décimos eso se ve más fácil si
escribimos 39 como 30 este 39
decimos
o sea que nos queda 30 décimos más nueve
décimos y luego treinta entre diez nos
da tres más nueve décimos nuestro
residuo ok entonces treinta y nueve
décimos son tres enteros y nueve décimos
y ahora si podemos comprar súper rápido
estas dos cantidades porque aquí tenemos
un entero ya otra cosa y aquí tenemos
tres enteros y otra cosa pero como son
tres enteros definitivamente este número
es más grande que uno entero y otra cosa
entonces uno y siete octavos es
estrictamente menor que treinta y nueve
décimos y este signo de menor lo
escribimos así porque pues esta es la
parte como que ancha y entonces el
número grande tiene que estar del lado
ancho y este piquito por acá pues es la
parte pequeña no entonces vamos a poner
el número más pequeño en la parte más
pequeña ahora vamos con cuatro y siete
octavos con respecto a 49 novenos el 9
cuántas veces caben en el 49 pues nueve
por cinco son 45 1 entonces y 9 cabeza
este es en el 49 y sobran 4 por lo cual
tenemos 4 novenos entonces otra vez
podemos nada más fijarnos en los enteros
y como 4 es definitivamente menor que 5
entonces ya sabemos que cuatro y siete
octavos es estrictamente menor que cinco
y cuatro novenos y bueno ahora vamos a
comparar dos y un medio con once decimos
ok este 11 decimos te me lo podemos
escribir como una fracción mixta
haciendo todas las cuentas directamente
en la cabeza o sea el 10 que había
exactamente una vez en el once y nos
sobra 1 o sea que tenemos 1 y un décimo
aja el 11 se puede escribir como 10 + 1
y si lo queremos dividir entre 10 pues
lo que nos queda es uno más un décimo
que hay uno y un décimo y entonces vemos
que esté entero 2 es más grande que este
entero 1 por lo tanto este número es
mayor
este número que es lo mismo que este
número y como siempre tenemos que poner
la puntita de este símbolo apuntando
hacia el número más pequeño de los dos
ok y la parte más grande se va a comer
al número más grande aquí lo podemos
poner unos dientes y este cocodrilo si
quiere comer obviamente el número más
grande y ahora vamos con cinco enteros y
cuatro novenos y queremos ver si es más
grande o más chico que 40 uy no aquí me
equivoqué aquí era 40 entre 7 no entre
entonces queremos 25 y 4 novenos es más
grande que 40 entre 7 entonces pues
vamos a escribir esto como un número
mixto 5 por 7 son 35 o sea que estos son
5 enteros y cinco séptimos bueno parece
que estoy haciendo vudú aquí pero
recuerda siempre recuerda que puedes
escribir esto como 7 por 5 35 más 5 y
estamos dividiendo todo entre 7 ok entre
7 y entre 7 y entonces todo esto es nada
más 15 enteros más esto de acá ahora
este es un ejemplo muy interesante
porque aquí lo que tenemos es que los
dos enteros son exactamente iguales
entonces ahora sí ahora sí ya nos
tenemos que fijar en la parte de la
fracción y este número va a ser más
chico o más grande que este número
dependiendo en si esta fracción es más
chica o más grande que esta fracción
entonces ustedes que dicen cuatro
novenos es más chico
más grande que cinco séptimos pues bueno
vamos a hacer la cuenta exacta no una de
las cosas que podemos hacer ahora es
convertir a estas dos fracciones en
algunas otras fracciones que tengan
denominador común entonces 9 por 7 63
entonces 63 puede ser un denominador
común así es que vamos a poner aquí 63 y
63 y haber para pasar de esta fracción a
esta fracción pues multiplicamos el
denominador que es 9 por un 7 para que
nos dé 63 entonces tenemos que agarrar
el numerador o sea 4 y multiplicarlo
también por 7 y bueno 4 por 7 es 28
entonces aquí va 28 ahora para pasar de
esta fracción a una fracción cuyo
denominador sea 63 tenemos que
multiplicar el 7 por 9 y ahora lo que
tenemos que hacer es multiplicar el
numerador también por 9 y 9 por 5 son 45
45 y bueno aquí ya
claramente cuál fracción es más grande
45 es más grande que 28 y tienen el
mismo denominador entonces esta fracción
es más grande que esta fracción 5 y 4
novenos es menor que 40 séptimos otra
cosa que pudimos haber hecho para
comparar estas dos fracciones era
comparar cuatro novenos con cuatro
séptimos aquí cuando tenemos dos
fracciones cuyo numerador es exactamente
el mismo podemos decir cuál fracción es
más grande que la otra porque el
denominador entre más grande sea el
número en este en este caso este es el
denominador más grande más chiquita son
las rebanadas del pastel
entonces si tomamos la misma cantidad de
rebanadas osea si tenemos el mismo
numerador pero tenemos un denominador
más grande y entonces las rebanadas son
más chicas pues entonces esta fracción
es más chica que esta otra fracción ok
entonces 4 novenos es más chico que 4
séptimos pero
4 séptimos es más chico que cinco
séptimos entonces esa es otra forma de
ver que cuatro novenos es más chico que
cinco séptimos